por primera vez mis padres me llevaron
eso comenzó una ruta de servicio
yo aprendí los mismos que los padres de
joe biden
para la presidencia de eeuu porque esos
valores siguen definiendo y tenemos que
restaurar estos valores y llevarlos de
nuevo a la casa blanca necesitamos un
comandante en jefe que cuide las tropas
de la misma manera que cuidaría su
propia familia
para joe biden eso no significa que
tenga que aprender viene de la
experiencia que comparte con municiones
de familias de militares cambiando a su
propio hijo a la guerra orando de a dios
para que pudiera volver seguro es un
presidente que todos tenemos el orgullo
de saludar y nunca dudaremos pues que él
estará con nuestros amigos
se enfrentarán nuestros adversarios
nunca lo contra él va a confiar
nuestros diplomáticos y las agencias de
inteligencia para que sea su trabajo
cuando alguien se enfrentará a nuestros
adversarios con fortaleza y con
experiencia ellos sabrán que él
porque desde el día uno va a restaurar
el liderazgo estadounidense y nuestra
autoridad moral será un presidente que
sabe que estados unidos es fuerte
como esperamos con el poder del ejemplo
y el ejemplo de nuestro poder para
restaurar el liderazgo de eeuu el idioma
de restaurar las alianzas que
necesitamos para atender las peligros
que enfrenta el país desde la
proliferación nuclear hasta el cambio
climático hoy somos un país dividido y
tenemos un presidente que hace todo en
su poder para que sea así y mantenernos
de saprissa qué diferencia será tener un
presidente que nos une que restaure
nuestra alma y nuestro corazón
creo que somos el mismo país que trabajo
mis padres a estas costas y qué
inspira en todo el mundo es en eeuu que
yo vuelva a liderar con el próximo
presidente gracias